Democrats and Republicans are
criticizing President Trump for not
specifically condemning white
supremacist and hate groups over the
violence in Charlottesville Virginia
Governor Terry McAuliffe called on the
President to take a stronger stand like
the President to come out today as I
asked every elected official in this
country
don't hide be strong and do the right
thing tell white supremists tell the
neo-nazis tell the KKK tell them all
we've had enough of it Margaret Brennan
is near the trump National Golf Club in
New Jersey Margaret good morning to you
good morning well an unnamed White House
official released a statement yesterday
condemning all extremist groups but
president Trump himself who campaigned
against political correctness has
avoided criticizing the white
supremacist behind the rally we have no
tolerance for hate and violence white
supremacist more than 36 hours after the
white supremacist rallies Vice President
Mike Pence became the highest-ranking
White House official to condemn the hate
groups these dangerous fringe groups
have no place in American public life
and in the American debate and we
condemned them in the strongest possible
terms that echoed in Vanko trump's
explicit announcement of the racism
white supremacy and neo-nazis behind the
unite the right rally President Trump
has denounced the violence but stopped
short of disavowing the hate groups
behind it we condemn in the strongest
possible terms this egregious display of
hatred bigotry and violence on many
sides on many sides that equivocal
statement drew criticism from
Republicans who faulted the president
for not distancing himself from the
white nationalist groups who backed his
candidacy and invoked his name at the
Saturday rally former KKK leader David
Duke we're gonna fulfill the promises
that's what we believed in that's why we
voted for that on Sunday White House
officials defended the president what
the President did is he called out
anyone anyone who is responsible for
fomenting this kind of bigotry hatred
racism
and-and-and violence but Republican
allies warned that the president's
silence on the matter
may speak volumes call this white
supremacism this white nationalism evil
and let the country here let the world
hear it National Security Adviser
general HR McMaster went a step further
than the president calling this an act
of terrorism
now President Trump is scheduled to make
a brief visit back to Washington today
he said he would hold a press conference
but Charlie there is nothing on his
official schedule at this time thanks
Margaret
the